على ذكر التاريخ ايضا احيل سيادتك الى
كتاب صدر عام 21 2021 شجرات من تاريخ
القاعده لابو خبيب بالسوداني وهو من
قيادات التنظيم وهو لا زال على قيد الحياه
موجود في اليمن هذا القياده موجود في
اليمن وقال انه استاجر ناصر الوحيشي الرجل
الثاني في تنظيم القاعده قبل مقتله
لكتابه هذه الشجرات التاريخيه المهمه جدا
في هذا الكتاب يذكر كيف تعاون اسامه بن
لادن والتنظيم في بدايه نشاته مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه على ذكر التعاون مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او القتال في
صف الولايات المتحده لا مشكله لدى هذه
التنظيمات ان تقاتل في الصف الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه او الغرب
طالما ان ذلك سوف ينهك ينهك الروس او ينهك
الغرب ذاته هم ينظرون الى هذه الحرب انها
سوف تنهك الطرفين ثم تعطيهم فرصه مثاليه
للتدريب وللتسلح وللبقاء وللوجود وللقتال
هذه فرصه غير مسبوقه كما كان يتحدث سبب
بلا دن حتى في بدايه ثورات الربيع العربي
يقول ان الثورات هذه فرصه غير مسبوقه
ستعطينا فرصه للحرب داخل المنطقه هذا ما
يحدث من هذه التنظيمات